washington sonia dridi sonia le
président abbey dawn a eu des mots forts
pour yves la dîmière poutine sera grâce
à ces sanctions un paria sur la scène
internationale
oui joe biden qui a dénoncé une attaque
préméditée en effet dit que vladimir
poutine allait être un paria sur la
scène internationale il a annoncé une
série de nouvelles sanctions contre la
russie allant notamment des sanctions
contre quatre banques russes
supplémentaires il a aussi assuré que
tous les actifs russes aux états unis
allaient être gelé il a annoncé des
sanctions contre des grandes entreprises
publiques russes et aussi la limitation
sur les exportations vers la russie joe
biden qui a assuré qu'entre les
sanctions des états unis et les
sanctions annoncées par les alliés
européens et bien cela allait permettent
de couper la moitié des importations
high tech donc technologique vers la
russie et donc que cela allait réduire
la capacité de la russie de développer
deux mots derniers sont moderniser son
industrie par exemple en ce qui concerne
le son programme spatial il a assuré que
cela allait être un coup porté à la
grande ambition de vladimir poutine et
il a aussi prévenu la russie que si et
bien elle tenté de faire des
cyberattaques de nouvelles
cyber-attaques contre les états unis les
états unis étaient prêts à riposter
joe biden qui n'a pas annoncé couper la
russie du système swift c'est ce que
certains évoqué comme hypothèse ces
derniers jours mais il a dit que cela
restait une option joe biden qui n'a pas
annoncé non plus de sanctions qui visent
directement vladimir poutine une
journaliste lui a posé la question après
cette conférence de presse mais il n'a
pas répondu à cette question pourquoi
pas des sanctions dirigées directement
contre vladimir poutine le président
américain qui a également répété que les
états unis n'avaient pas envoyé de
troupes en ukraine mais il a annoncé
qu'il pour qu'il y aurait un déploiement
de troupes supplémentaires américaine en
allemagne cela avec la coordination de
l'otan est il a aussi dire que ces
dernières semaines les états unis
avaient prévenu le monde de ce qui
allait se passer notamment en partageant
des informations déclassifiées avec le
reste du monde il a déclaré poutine
cherche à imposer sa vision du monde
vision que les etats-unis et leurs
alliés combattrons oui
joe biden à qui estime que la démarche
de vladimir poutine vise ni plus ni
moins car reconstituer l'urss et le dit
les relations entre les etats-unis et la
russie seront coupés dorénavant
oui c'est ce qu'il a déclaré il a aussi
beaucoup insisté sur l'unité de du reste
du monde face à la russie sur l'unité
des alliés de l'otan et c'est un point
important pour les états unis qui ont
aussi été qui ont selon beaucoup ici
d'observateurs à washington ont retenu
les leçons après le chaos du retrait
américain d'afghanistan où les alliés de
l'otan s'étaient sentis feu consulter
délai c'est donc là les états unis
insistent vraiment sur le fait de
l'unité avec le reste des alliés de
l'otan face à la russie sur le fait que
toute nation qui se joindra à la russie
dans cette agression sera aussi
considéré comme un paria sur la scène
internationale joe biden qui a déclaré
l'histoire montrera que le choix que
poutine a fait or a affaibli la russie
et va renforcer le reste du monde merci
sonia dridi avec nous en direct de
washington